bonsoir mais ryanair à merci d'être avec
nous en direct par téléphone sur rtl
france il ya donc dix ans le mot liberté
résonné sur la place tahrir en egypte
qu'en reste-t-il aujourd'hui bien il en
reste une société civile qui vous le
voyez pour certains segments n'a pas
renoncé à réclamer ses droits à mekla
mais surtout plus de justice locale
parce que quand on parle de droit c'est
surtout les inégalités les injustices
qui était visé par la révolution 2009
donc on a un pan de la population
égyptienne qui m'a pas qu'il n'est pas
résigné par rapport à cet objectif et
qui voudraient qu'une nouvelle
contestation d'ampleur prennent place
pour modifier la donne et puis on a
quand même aussi une autre partie de la
population qui allait plutôt rallié au
régime en réalité à alarmer et qui s'est
fait une raison quant à a
quant à cette révolution cela n'a pas
apporté grand chose aux égyptiens enfin
j'ai aussi l'impression qui prévaut chez
g20 certain nombre d'entre eux donc
c'est pour ça qu'on ne voit pas
d'ailleurs de résurgence révolutionnaire
est donc ça veut dire en gros en résumé
peut-être que les heat s'est débarrassé
d'un homme mais pas d'un régime
non mais le régime mais j'avais tomber
en réalité l'état l'état égyptien est un
régime militaire l'armée a un rôle
central
historiquement par ailleurs l'egypte est
très touchée par le terrorisme donc bien
évidemment l'armée a eu des arguments
pour établir son contrôle après 2011
et bien évidemment même pendant la
période de prise d'arrivée du pouvoir
des frères musulmans avant la déposition
de deux mois maintenant si l'armée
n'avait pas du tout disparu du paysage
il fallait s'attendre à ce qu'elles par
cette contre révolution pour prendre les
rênes du pays
et aujourd'hui j'ai par du thé du
terrorisme ne fait le principal argument
d'un évidemment que que les égyptiens
oppose à tout ce qui leur parle de
droits fondamentaux de droits de l'homme
et de démocratie alors selon un rapport
d'amnesty international injustement les
emprisonnements sous le gouvernement
maréchal elle si sion ont explosé ces
dernières années est ce qu on fait face
un gouvernement encore plus répressif
que celui de hosni moubarak
oui d'une certaine manière moi j'ai
toujours considéré que finalement
l'autoritarisme et était beaucoup plus
prononcée aujourd'hui en egypte qu'il ne
l'était pour la simple et bonne raison
que le gouvernement d'hosni moubarak
avait procédé à une ouverture à la fin à
la fin de son pouvoir alors une
ouverture très relative mais il y avait
tout de même des pas de chaise à la
société civile et puis 2011 en quelque
sorte par la violence des événements et
puis la fragmentation si la société gif
scène tout cela le terrorisme d'état
islamique tout cela a créé des tensions
qui entache et finalement une transition
je dirais sereine vers vers un régime
plus ouvert plus qui conseille des
libertés alors une démocratie
occidentale sans doute pas mais un
régime plus ouvert et ça a été
complètement mon avis remis en cause par
la suite des événements pour quelle
raison justement ça a été aussi
compliqué et remis en cause s'estimant
pas d'une part parce que l'armée
toujours rester aux commandes en réalité
comme je lé précisé l'armée face à la
violence des événements a en quelque
sorte transiger en temps pour ensuite
reprendre la main et donc pour chasser
les frères musulmans est dans le giron
des frères musulmans toute l'opposition
en fait
ensuite on a eu des actions terroristes
extrêmement violentes et meurtrières en
egypte qui ont encore donné davantage
d'arguments aux militaires pour reha
soir leur pouvoir et se donne aussi pour
ça que beaucoup d'égyptiens aujourd'hui
soutiennent en fait le régime en disant
que voilà que que que sans ce régime
militaire sans un pouvoir fort
l'egypte va sombrer dans le chaos dans
le terrorisme anarchique des rats et
puis évidemment les égyptiens sont très
au courant qui passe en syrie en irak en
libye qui le pays voisin et craignent
par dessus tout cette descente dans une
potentielle guerre civile en cas de de
déliquescence du pouvoir donc on fait le
pari du rpt du pouvoir forte chez
certains égyptiens
on les a pas entendus
reportage mais il est important de le
dire merci menem mènera politologue
spécialiste du moyen-orient merci
d'avoir été avec nous